is it helpful to be pushing for that as
you're trying to get a deal you know we
are prepared to get back into the deal
as soon as possible as soon as iran is
and we would lift all of the sanctions
that are inconsistent with the jcpoa but
in the meantime we can't stand by and
not be prepared for world in which iran
may be choosing to delay build its
program try to build more leverage we
obviously have to respond and so that's
what we're doing we're preparing
ourselves for that that outcome how
concerned
are you or how concerned is the united
states that
israel could potentially drag the united
states into an armed conflict with iran
we are
privileging the path of diplomacy we
think it's the best way we think it's
best for us we suspect it's best for
iran but iran will have to decide but as
president biden as secretary blinken
have both said if iran chooses regard
despite our diplomatic offer to take a
different path then we'll have to use
the the tools at our disposal to make
sure that iran does not acquire a
nuclear weapon
why should iran trust the united states
though given the fact that it knows full
well that a 2024 presidential election
could bring another president
that could completely undo any of the
efforts you're making right now this is
not a deal that is based on trust and so
it's not we don't trust iranians the
iranians don't trust us and what
happened when the us withdrew from the
deal is that iran started ramping up its
nuclear program that's why president
biden is is back and has given us the
mandate to try to get back into the deal
and he would not be expending this
political capital and making this effort
if his goal was to come in and then
withdraw of course we don't know what a
future president will do we don't know
what the future iranian leadership will
do but we think that it's in our mutual
interest to get back in the deal would
the united states be willing at any
point to meet face to face with iranian
negotiators we're prepared to meet with
them face to face we think it's far
superior to indirect negotiations when
we're dealing with something this
complex with so much so much mistrust
with so much potential for
misunderstanding so we've said we'll
meet at any time in any place they're
the ones who are not prepared to do it
for their own reasons we think it's a
mistake we think it's a mistake that
hurts both of us we know that these
talks are not open-ended the united
states has made that clear
what's the time frame we're looking for
as i've said before this is a
technological clock it's not a
chronological clock in other words if
they slow down their nuclear program
would have more time if they continue at
the current pace then time is running
out secretary blinken has made that
clear over and over again time is
running out and we and the europeans
will have to conclude if if iran
continues on down this path that they
have killed the jcpoa and the jcpoa
would be no more we hope that's not the
case we are fully committed to a mutual
return to compliance uh with the jcpoa
we think there's still time to do it if
iran comes back and says they're
prepared to roll up their sleeves and do
it too